along the eastern seaboard deformations
of Canada geese fly overhead every
spring and fall despite their name
Canada geese are found across North
America and have even been introduced to
parts of Europe and New Zealand adapted
to live in marshy meadows and wetlands
they fare equally well in city parks and
farmlands Canada geese follow a strict
migratory path with traditional stopover
points along the way most will follow
the same route for the rest of their
lives
here they'll rest and refuel when
feeding under water they drag their
bills across the bottom serrated edges
along their bills easily slice through
vegetation any small animal caught up is
an extra bonus though primarily
herbivores some geese populations have
been known to eat insects fish and even
clams the bill makes an excellent
grooming tool as well feathers must be
kept in excellent shape
once recharged they'll take to the skies
and continue their journey they are
strong and streamlined fliers a flock
may cover 1500 miles in a single day the
V formations reduce wind resistance and
help keep the flock coordinated Canada
geese mate for life
each year the females return to the same
nesting site to lay their eggs family
bonds are extremely strong chicks begin
signaling to the parents when they're
still in the egg once hatched the baby
Gosling's will stay with the family for
up to a year they learn from their
parents how to find food how to
communicate how to swim and fly and when
they are old enough
the migration routes they will follow
year after year flying high overhead as
the seasons go by